[Music]
all right we obviously have to talk
about gun control this week over the
course of my many Rubin report
interviews I've sat across from an array
of people who are pro-gun rights
anti-gun altogether or somewhere in
between
while the events surrounding the gun
conversation are always horrific with
this week's tragic events in Vegas being
perhaps the worst of all of them I
believe that the conversation around
guns when done right can offer powerful
insight into how people think about
society at large gun ownership and the
right to bear arms brings up issues
about the American Constitution states
rights personal responsibility mental
health radicalization both religious and
otherwise and much more unfortunately as
is so often the case these days were
seemingly caught between two groups of
people the people who want to ban guns
completely and the people who don't want
to have any sort of conversation about
sensible gun laws well I absolutely
support the Second Amendment I at the
same time understand and acknowledge
that the United States has what seems to
be a unique problem related to mass gun
violence lost in the midst of all the
awful events of Las Vegas this week are
other senseless shootings across the
country like the five people killed and
30 others wounded by gunfire in Chicago
this past weekend the weekend before
that three were killed and 36 were
wounded in Chicago and the weekend
before that it was 11 dead and 29
wounded in the very same city we've
included a link down below which tracks
the gun related violence across Chicago
occurring every single weekend and it's
disturbing to say the least I bring up
Chicago not to deflect from the events
in Las Vegas but to show how this
murderous violence is happening in one
of our biggest cities literally every
single day and happening so often at
this point that the mainstream media has
all but given up on reporting on it the
reasons behind how and why people murder
others also makes it hard to find one
law around guns that works in every
situation there no doubt is a difference
between a murder that occurs during a
robbery versus gang violence versus
terrorism versus suicides versus a
random shooter with no known political
or religious motive
and at the same time there are times
when someone with the gun saves innocent
lives during a shootout or when someone
defends their property and their family
by having a gun in the home so again
while I support the Second Amendment I
also recognize that we undoubtably
have a gun related violence problem on
our hands just look at the numbers I can
also acknowledge that guns in and of
themselves aren't the only problem here
without question much of the carnage
caused by guns is due to people with
mental health issues gaining access to
guns the truth is that if I or most of
the gun owners in America had access to
the most deadly weapons on earth we
wouldn't be randomly using those weapons
against innocent people not only are
mental health issues an aspect to the
people who are committing mass shootings
but also there's a problem with any any
ideology which drives people to commit
these heinous acts be it a religious
ideology a political ideology or any
other system of principles or beliefs
which could drive someone to kill a
weapon in and of itself can't kill
anyone it takes a human being and a
corrupt thought process to pull the
trigger and kill innocent people also as
I'm recording this it's still unclear
exactly what weapons were used in Vegas
but authorities report to finding about
20 other firearms in the shooters hotel
room and it's possible that this man was
using a military-style fully automatic
rifle to commit this heinous act for all
the defense I've offered up the Second
Amendment I cannot see I can't possibly
see how access to such weapons which
have the ability to mow down civilians
at an incredible rate and which are
designed for the battlefield should be
in the hands of regular citizens as we
post this video the story about the
Vegas gunman is largely incomplete at
the moment we don't seem to know his
motives so it's hard to say if this was
an act of terrorism under the most
specific definition of the term which
includes having a political motivation
to kill Nevada States definition is a
little more broad not including the need
for a political motivation which in this
case would in fact classify this killer
as a terrorist regardless of how we
wanted to find this specific act of
horrific violence or how the gun
discussion relates to terror
tourism or the legitimate right of every
citizen to have the ability to defend
themselves
we must get better about talking about
gun control between the shootings in
order to prevent more shootings and not
just talk about it when these acts occur
passing more laws in the heat of emotion
is rarely the right thing to do even if
they are well intentioned while doing
nothing and hoping that these events
will simply end is just as misguided as
hoping the Terrorism will completely
stop if we just ignore it while we wait
to find out more about the Vegas shooter
himself and at the same time mourn the
victims of this evil act
we should also continue to talk to
people on both sides of the gun debate
to try to come to some sensible place of
agreement I'm gonna do my best to do
just that and if you guys know of some
interesting voices in this debate that
you'd like to hear on the Reuben report
let us know in the comments section
right down below
[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn Liberty this week and joining me
is a columnist a media personality and
the author of dear reader the
unauthorized autobiography of Kim Jong
Il Michael now let's welcome to the
Reuben report hello Kim Jung ill and yet
when you see that online sometimes it
looks like Kim Jung too
that's true al that must be very
confusing to people only if they're like
you know IQ of 100 hilarious I said to
you right before we started I was doing
a little research and then people see
Kim jong-un yeah Carla and then you got
one you got ill people think it's a 2
you could see why there would be some
language confusion there I think well
it's also funny when people think Kim is
his first name because that's the family
name and in Asia they have the last name
first and some people refer to him as
like little Kim it's like that's not it
yeah it's not good Google a little
kaminer a whole other thing comes up
very entertaining all right there's a
ton I want to talk you about I'm looking
forward to talking about North Korea
because I think it's actually one of the
one of the countries and and from a part
of the world that we haven't spent a lot
of time we talked
about you know obviously domestic stuff
and some middle-east stuff but we
haven't spent that much time in that
part of the world but first I just want
to find out a little more about you
you've been interesting biography you
just told me a couple pieces of trivia
about yourself that I think are quite
interesting so for people who have no
idea who Michael malice is who are you
well that's that's a broad kind of oh
who am I to start I'm the boy you love
to hate I like you said I'm an author
I'm on TV you know running my big fat
mouth frequently I host a show on
compound Mediacom and the in the Fox
family I see you on a lot of the Fox the
business yeah you know when I started
this North Korea work it was driving me
crazy that there's so many people on TV
and in other forms of media who are
running their mouths about this country
which is extremely complicated and they
have no idea what they're talking about
and you know quoting Atlas Shrugged I
said I'm gonna put a stop to this once
and for all and I kind of did the
conversation I started shifting from you
know we just need to bomb them into
oblivion to this is a nation of what is
it 25 million slaves and our hearts
should go out to them because there are
absolute victims of this horrible regime
you know I was on an NPR affiliate it's
very funny and she was referred to Kim
jong-il as it can't be figure and I said
well that's a very unfortunate choice of
words and she was rendered pretty much
suicidal because again they have
concentration camps you can see them on
Google Earth so whenever you see the
press making North Korea out to be a
carnival this is exactly what I'm
against yeah and I that's actually one
of the things that I really want to dive
into a little bit because I find it to
be one of those things where anything
happens you know there's a missile test
that now seems to be happening every
week or whatever else the amount of
people and again you can't pay too much
attention to what's happening on Twitter
but just the amount of misinformation
Fuzion joking about extremely serious
things when people have no idea what the
consequences are all that there's just
like it's just a whole series yeah I was
on a radio show this week and the hosts
were just cracking jokes about North
Korea and I wasn't having and he's like
oh you gotta let me have my jokes ago
it's like North Korean missiles you got
to make sure that they land so the book
is humorous because I'm like if you can
make people laugh about this situation
you can get them to understand the
darkness because otherwise it's too
intense you know there's this amazing
we're called nothing to envy and you
read it and you want to jump out of
window because we're so powerless to
help these people but the
same time it's I think it's important to
understand both North Korea specifically
and generally how you know totalitarian
governments work and what that means in
practice you know is more than the
Soviet Union so this is something that
hits very close to home for me yeah so
all right before we dive fully into that
you mentioned right before we started
you just referenced Iran you mentioned
that you have her did you say it's her
first print first copy I have
Iran's copy of the first edition of The
Fountainhead yes that seems like you
can't it doesn't even exist well I also
have it I also have the dress she was
buried in don't get it I do have that
book I mean I'm a book collector I've
got every book she's ever written and
and I stopped after a while because now
with self-publishing people can read
books about her they're not worth
reading but to a point I had every book
written by and about her yeah I mean she
was a huge influence on me but at the
same time I don't often like talking
about it because for a certain
percentage of the population higher than
10% less than 50% saying you like Iran
takes the mental space of saying you're
Scientologists most people just check
out they think it's a cult and there's
something to that so I mean I'm very
kind of wary of getting into the whole
Iran stuff yeah it's so interesting to
me because I've been doing some work
with the Iran people and mostly we're
just promoting free speech on college
campuses and I found them to be some of
the most open decent protecting the
things that I care about with free
speech and all of those things and yet I
know for sure and I there were people
I've had on this show that'll say Oh
Iran this or that just completely in a
dismissive way and maybe they've got
some branding work to do one of the
things that drives me crazy and this is
that maybe my Soviet upbringing is do
not eat your own so the kinds of people
who go after Rand or rothbard or any of
these other great titans of Liberty who
had many many flaws and who did many
messed-up things if your agenda is to
take down the people who broke down
those doors for you you are in my view
garbage as a human being and it's it's
really reprehensible for me to see I
mean the villain is the state the
villain are the people who want to
dominate and control free people's lives
and you should always keep that in mind
as opposed to some kind of social
posturing you know I really like the way
you phrase that because we see so much
bickering inner bickering we have people
these days and all the personal attacks
and all the labels and all that stuff
and it's like you guys all don't have
your eyes on the prize right we should
be fighting for his freedom what we
should be fighting for is to expand
Liberty all the things that you just
mentioned and instead we're just like at
each other's throats all day with people
that have virtually no control over
anybody and we should be at the throats
of people who are sending those to war
for no reason who are sending people to
prison for no reason who are trying to
censor free speech for no reason they're
the villains so if you don't like how
someone talks or things you judge people
by their actions not by their thoughts
yeah all right well let's talk about
some ideas then so okay North Korea yeah
the juichi idea what in the world
possessed you to go to North Korea you
even say I went to North Korea to people
they think this guy's something's not
right well there's a few reasons one is
when I got established enough as a
writer I had some money in my pocket and
I thought I'm going to travel more right
this is something I never allowed myself
to do when I was kind of struggling and
North Korea was first on my list first
of all you have party cred because you
can always tell people you've never been
yeah yeah that's very impressed
I saw grimness said it's the most real
yeah but also you know you get older
people want to see what their family
went through and for me the only time
capsule of Soviet Russia is you know
North Korea it's the closest so and I
also wanted to see what it's like it's
the only country we don't have internet
access you don't access the outside
world my friend had gone and it's it was
it was until recently illegal to go so
and I wanted to do a book about it
because it's it's such a fascinating
country and I thought to myself look we
have a pretty good here if I move the
needle in America it's not going to
matter but if I move the needle in North
Korea even a little bit this could be
saving you know millions of lives and
yeah it's a pompous thing to do but I'd
rather shoot for the moon and miss then
you know kind of like have some kind of
marginal tax cut here yeah although I
would like to believe that you can move
the needle here and it would still have
some movement sure otherwise why why
would any of us do what we do right yeah
that's fair yeah let's just pause for a
second so tell me a little bit more
about Soviet Russia cuz I don't I don't
want to gloss over that so you were born
there yeah when did you you and your
family we came here when I was two but
you know you grew up we're in a Soviet
household it's it's funny and as you get
older talking to Americans and realizing
oh this is not how everyone is raised
right and how you how so how much
programming
in my head as a result of how I grew up
and it's it's just fascinating that this
you we all think of our families as the
norm yeah and then you go to college and
you grow up and you're like oh no this
is just my family that's messed up and
that's like for me it's like it's not
just my family it's this whole culture
yeah well everyone's family is messed up
to different degrees and absolutely ruin
things what's it like growing up so okay
came here too so you obviously don't
remember what it was like to be in the
Soviet Union but with parents that lived
through that and then come here as
immigrants what was that experience like
I mean English is my second language and
the first thing they did was send me to
private school because they knew that
public schools would be the death of me
which I'm very very grateful for but
there's just so many little
idiosyncrasies like you know Russia is a
no trust Society so you're you're you
kind of have this paranoia built into
your head which frankly when you're
dealing in entertainment or media it's
useful to have no it's not you're
prepared for that person to kind of
screw you over but also the fact that
most people in life are generally
incompetent so if you have these backup
plans or when someone messes up
intentionally or not
it kind of moves you well in business at
the same time it's hard for making
personal relationships because you're
paranoid and assuming everyone's that to
get you a no trust Society yeah an
interesting phrase and I sense we're
sort of viewing to that oh yes how in
America that there is just a basic sense
that first off yeah you barely trust the
people that you're getting information
from but it's not even that we're also
having trouble agreeing on facts which i
think is a much more dangerous thing
these facts I think that's a very
healthy thing because I think what we
need to do is self segregate we already
starts to self segregate by ideology
even having these same arguments since
the flesh revolution I don't want to
argue anymore
I want you to go your way we'll go our
way and everyone will be the better for
it interesting so you don't think if if
we disagree politically on certain
things you kind of want to let each
faction just go its own way as opposed
to try to get something together oh yeah
the best thing about Trump for me is
that he's increasingly making political
discourse impossible because when you
have political discourse that can only
mean oppression because that can only
mean when both parties get together it's
all it's going to be at the expense of
freedom so when you see for example it's
unfolding as we're taping this all right
now so when we air this
we'll see which way it has gone when you
see Trump working with the Democrats
that on something like daca you view
that as sort of a this can't be good and
then right correct they can't be good
but I don't know that it is it's gonna
play out exactly like it seems because
Trump has been very good at pulling the
rug out from people and humiliating him
and he's been a great wrecking ball in
terms of bringing disapproval and
distaste or the political process yeah
so as someone that grew up with parents
from the former Soviet Union and went
through all this stuff and understands
this this trust issue yeah I sense
you're you're basically a Trump guy
right no I'm an anarchist I mean I think
these people shall be in jail but I
think it's great that he is they're
giving me a lot here I'm gonna have to
have a chart here's an example of how
the Soviet upbringing really helped me
yeah this thing with that guy from
Google James yeah when people were
shocked how it played out I'm like it
was mind-boggling to me that people were
naive enough to be surprised there be
any other consequence when you have that
mindset you know the the essential Sofia
thought is if someone has power of you
arbitrary power you should assume that
they're going to exploit it completely
unfairly arbitrarily and always be aware
of who had for example I have a landlord
and there's a problem with my sink and
my friends like why didn't you tell him
you know and and say you know make a
fuss about I go what he's just gonna do
is fix the sink and let's say cost $200
you just raise my rent by $200 a look
well he can't do that I'm like he can
when people have power over you they
will use that power and I think it's
very naive for many Americans to think
that you know politicians are in any way
beholden to you or care about you in any
way where for them you're just a
resource to exploit interesting so on
the domore front so if it played out
exactly as you expect right do you think
there's a net good or bad by what
happened in other words so I had him on
the show he was on Joe Rogan's show he
got a lot of press and when I think when
he gets some of those ideas out there I
think that's actually a net good for
society but you think the process is
just obvious what's gonna happen this
guy went against the narrative and of
course this is what's gonna the net good
and Trump has done this very well is
getting the veneer of civility to be
exposed from the event evangelical left
and showing that yet
we'll be nice if they need to but they
have no problem being very nasty if they
want to and the more that is exposed the
more the sneering the literal violence
the calls for I mean these people would
be glad to have gulags if they had their
way so the more that is exposed than
this veneer respectability that people
in suits in Washington have that is to
me is the best good that came out of
this I think that's the first time
anyone said the evangelical left yeah I
usually go regressive left I've heard
control left all it left all that other
stuff but it's interesting because it
does have a as some of my guests have
said Peter Bogosian that this sort of
post modernist leftist stuff that there
is a secular religion sort of developing
well I always say that uh progressivism
is Christianity without the mythology so
they don't believe in a Christ figure
but they definitely have means of
redemption they definitely think of
systemic racism is conceptually
identical to original sin you know I'm
writing a book on the new right this is
all laid out in there but these are
religious people who hate heretics and
they hate them with the fury of a
thousand suns and once you realize that
that's their ammo and I don't mean
everyone on the left there are plenty of
people in left we're like we need some
welfare people should be discriminated
against so on and so forth I'm all for
that
I mean people who are like you can't
have your ideas anywhere on earth or
even in the future or in outer space in
like sci-fi or videogames that is an
evangelical approach yeah and as we talk
about this right now it's to the
backdrop of ben shapiro
gave his big speech and look it
basically went off okay yeah there was
some bounds I guess there were a couple
arrests but the craziness that had to
happen beforehand to even get it to
happen
I heard that Berkeley had to put
$600,000 worth of security and just to
make this thing happen and that does
sort of prove your point all Ben did was
talk about ideas I watched it he did not
say one bigoted or racist thing you may
not like his ideas you may not like his
policies but of course these are ideas
that should be heard but I disagree with
you because their definition of racist
is that which is not progressive so
though so they view it as race for sure
but in the scheme of reality what am i
what i would call objective reality but
nothing he said was raising the thing is
if you are allowing racism to dictate
the terms of discourse you've already
allowing them to establish the rules and
and this is something Trump has done
very effectively because for years for
decades racist was this huge term that
used to you know completely destroy
people that didn't work with him so now
they've ratcheted it up to white
nationalist white supremacist Nazi all
of trumps children married Jewish people
and yet he's told with a straight face
that he's a literal Klansmen and
literally Hitler yeah I married an
immigrant and he married an immigrant
yes and who's beautiful so the more that
they have to say things that are
ridiculous on their face the healthier
it is for our country yeah all right so
taking this back because I can see
you've got a consistent line I think you
here well thank you this back from what
I could see so far but give me a chance
here okay taking this back to you to
your family and and coming from the
Soviet Union how much of this was always
built-in like did they did they have
their wake up to power like when you
guys got here were they immediately like
oh we we understand what living under
that was like or did they suddenly then
they were in freedom the freedoms of the
West and then started realizing what it
was like oh no they really I mean it's
the same it's the same thing just sliced
differently yeah and you know like one
of the things I was on a BBC radio show
this was ten years ago and I just
repeated something that my father said
about the police which I won't do here
and the host kind of audibly gasped and
said this is a family show so the
perception of authority when you're
coming from that background as opposed
to America is very very different and it
was kind of shocking to me to see I'd
adjusted recently just a grand jury duty
and to see how easily people fall in
select the Milgram experiment this idea
that Authority can be bestowed and we
should be subservient to someone else
for any reason whatsoever is it
something that's very alien to my
upbringing in my thinking yeah how did
they let you on a grand jury did I ask
you anything i explicitly I explicitly
said I'm an anarchist and I will not
vote to indict under any circumstances
and they said too bad you're on the
grand jury my rabbit will I work that
grand jury like nobody's business
yeah it was beautiful I can't talk about
it legally but let's say that if you
have one of the reasons I'm not a big
fan democracy if you have one smart
person and a group of people who don't
have much principles at all it's very
easy for that one person to leave the
herd yeah
off the record maybe later you have to
tell me some of that stuff sure
but that's in that's an incredible
indictment of our criminal justice
system if you can literally walk into
the grand jury and say guys I'm an
anarchist I don't believe in any of this
is all nonsense
and they're going yeah get going yeah
and I made those assistant das look very
very upset yeah why would they want you
why would they need to have bodies it's
just that they just need bodies they
need to fill those twenty whatever slots
yeah
how far does your anarchism go to the
core what do you mean well I mean really
like you would deconstruct the
government altogether I mean well I
would say there's nothing this is the
endless debate I think between
libertarians and and the people that are
further to the right like what's the
point are we talking okay no more
driver's licenses and then or are we
talking about you know private courts
and oh absolutely so it's not a function
of deconstructing government per se so
much as atheists don't want to kill God
right if you send a atheist wants to
kill God that doesn't make any sense
right so it's more the idea that the
idea of government is itself
illegitimate it's this every criticism
that Bernie Sanders and all these other
people have the corporations are true
but the biggest corporation is the
government which has government schools
which teaches you that it's a good thing
that this corporation can steal what 40%
of your income and you should be
grateful for it and it can provide you
crappy qualities and crappy quality
products and make you feel unsafe and
then the only answer is more things
that'll make you feel unsafe that
concept I don't understand how people
don't get because this idea that what I
hear Bernie and the rest of these guys
complain about is the government can't
you know they complain about obviously
private companies and right that and big
corporations but then there's always
this the government's corrupt
everything's corrupt we're all corrupt
and evil blah blah blah give us more
money make us bigger well it's also that
this filthy moth-eaten hippie Bernie
Sanders to watch him defending the CIA
which is like the bete noire of the
hippie movement was mind-boggling but
also shows that the tribal mindset that
anyone who is on our side is good and
anyone who's against us in the moment is
bad you remember during the Obama years
we had this whole honeymoon with Putin
you know Russians our friend now the
Cold War is a is a embarrassment the
past
Mitt Romney you're so stupid in the
1980s called and now Putin is literally
Hitler I have not heard one reason in
the press why Putin is supposed to be
hated other than his interests are not
aligned with
which applies to every country on earth
right so do you think that Russia was
involved in the election in any way or
you know every day there's another story
about this they generally get hit down
after about two weeks IIIi don't know
and I don't really care because I mean
everyone tried to stop Trump I mean he
didn't have like literally no newspaper
endorsements you had organizations that
didn't endorse anyway Lee supported or
whatever but I mean you remember many
Trump you remember how quickly it went
from Russia Russia Russia to
Charlottesville Charlottesville
Charlottesville so it's only a matter of
what weapon will we have to defeat our
opposition yeah what do you make of that
just that sort of endless parade of we
focus on this for three days we're all
outraged about that then then we
literally forget about it and we move on
to some other outrage usually sparked by
someone we've never heard of in a place
we don't care and then now we're gonna
just endlessly folk it this is one of
the reasons I like the left better than
conservatives and consider conservatism
the vilest of all political philosophies
because they think you can sit down with
these people and have some kind of
meeting of the minds and then you're
going to come out some kind of agreement
in the middle whereas as you said every
three days this story's changed these
people are not playing some kind of fair
game they're they're engaged in war and
you know if you're on the right you
shouldn't be for unilateral disarmament
this was a motif of the far left so
that's interesting so you like them work
as you respect a certain authenticity
about it even if you don't like the
ideas you like that there's a sort of
realness to the game and they appreciate
culture which conservatives often do not
and and do not understand where culture
comes from I mean I live in Brooklyn and
I live in Brooklyn for a reason so I
think the left exploits many very good
ideas and principles that people have to
a very unhealthy degree yeah what do you
mean you live in Brooklyn for reason
meaning that it is cultured I think it's
culturally left I mean I mean it's a
very left-wing and though I don't agree
necessarily people politically
culturally this whole idea of you know
having diversity of idea diversity of
expression and all these other things is
just absolutely wonderful now it's not
for everyone and if you don't like it
that's perfectly fine I'm not going to
judge you for it like most of my
colleagues will but at the same time you
have to appreciate the left is has its
power for a reason it's not just getting
ability out of nowhere it's it's taking
it from something so it's focusing on
the cultural stuff so the Hollywood
stuff the movies right all of that so
it's interesting you said I think you
said conservatives have no culture right
but I mean I think you that was a little
bit of hyperbole right no not none is a
capable of creating culture whatsoever
really yes I'll even tell your story can
you see my shoes I can't so I made by a
conservative but that's my point I was
in the green room and a prominent
conservator who I won't name looked at
them and he's like what are you wearing
and it's not like I had like octopus
wrapped around my feet it's just
newsprint print and he's seen newsprint
he's seen shoes maybe it's a little
weird but he couldn't wrap his head
around it so so much of conservatism is
based on this site a version of if this
is new and I haven't seen it before I
don't like it and which is why so much
of like conservatives like crappy TV
like I don't know how I Met Your Mother
because they take innovative ideas
corporations do digest them and excrete
them in ways that these people can find
palpable and to me that's just the
nature of culture that's interesting you
know you probably saw a little bit about
you know Tim Allen's show that's been on
these last couple years I haven't last
man standing okay was it sort of you
know standard sitcom you know not too
far from what home improvement was his
main show but he played a conservative
in it and all the jokes were
conservative jokes oh they were mocking
the Atheist son and they would make
global warming jokes and stuff and I
watch it a couple of times and I was
like this isn't the funniest thing I've
ever seen generally these sitcoms are
pretty correct and yeah it feels like
you're watching something from another
time right but that being said I was
like oh they're at least doing something
reverse of what you're being pushed sure
at all the time and I was like there's
something at least good there and of
course then it was cancelled and perhaps
because it was but any community will
tell you he once laughs not applause so
if you're getting and so much of leftist
comedy is based on and again this is
leftism at its worst is based on I think
you're funny because I agree with you
that's not how humor works humor works
if I think you're funny because you made
a connection that I haven't yes I don't
like to works right I mean we've talked
about that a bit a bunch on the show
that like the leftist comics these days
it's like well that you 90% of any
artistry in any field is always going to
be garbage I mean you know 90% of
podcast a terrible
90 percent commune is a terrible 90% of
books tell in fact when I started
becoming an author I read this amazing
book by Dennis Johnson called Jesus's
son I didn't realize he was a poet and
it made me distraught I'm never gonna be
able to write this well and then yeah
I'm like I don't have to write as well
as him I could write as well as me and
when I tell people how to get into
writing I go look at how many crappy
books are out there that could be you
you could be that mediocre author and
when you put in those terms people find
it aspirational I'm in the middle of
writing my first book is that so
wonderfully that's a very powerful
statement right there yeah I'm gonna
look at it I mean every day I look at it
I'm like man this is crap and then three
hours later I like it and then I chew it
again
don't edit as you write that is that you
made that mistake I've started
controlling myself guys I have enough
friends many whose books are right here
that have said to me don't edit yeah
you're right it's against my nature
right you know but I'm trying writing is
not a natural process even for people
who are communicators like us it's a
very tough rigorous process that's kind
of like nails on a chalkboard at least
for me yeah all right I do want to go
deep on North Korea let's just do a
little bit more here first because I
wasn't intending on going this route
when I'm with you okay so you start
writing and then you start appearing on
these TV shows saying what you think all
this stuff it seems like we don't have a
lot of people these days who will say
what they think with some actual
knowledge mind it everyone's saying
something sure but but to actually have
an understanding of what you're talking
about do you find that when you're doing
a lot of these cable shows because I'll
watch some of these things sometimes and
I'm like man these people don't know
what they're talking about in their
defense they have to be effectively have
opinions on everything under the Sun
like I didn't know who Tom Brady was but
that night we were going to talk about
him and had to have an opinion on him
right you know Tom Brady whoa no I did
not
hey Gavin didn't you like comic books
more than football Gavin McInnes didn't
even know that the Patriots were out of
Boston so I had one up on him so but I I
think that's tough I think a lot of
people's role and there's nothing wrong
with that is to be a talking point
machine and then to represent their side
because the person at home was like a
good Republican wants to see their good
Republican view portrayed on screen I
think the people are smarter not that
there's not that they're dumb but it's
very hard to be quick and articulate and
informed about anything so it's a very
small pool to draw
I think yeah and a lot of people have
told me and I never thought about until
after I did it that what I do is their
worst nightmare because they're not able
to kind of answer questions on the spot
and I guess for people like us it's just
something that either comes natural
something we learned yeah it's funny
because anytime I do one of these things
or when I do a public speaking event or
something I always feel that less
preparation of course I want to know
what I'm talking to the topic that I'm
giving a speech about or something like
that but beyond that less preparation
and being able to hear someone when they
do it I love q and A's because it's like
you thought of something and now I will
respond naturally and not in a canned
way and yet we watch people on TV all
day that it's like we could be watching
the same thing that they said three
years ago a mother and as the audience
you enjoy the spontaneity my favorite
thing is when I'm on one of these shows
and someone who sees me as humorous
therefore thinks I'm a silly clown and
they come for me and I just eviscerate
them and the person at home knows this
wasn't planned this is off the top of
the head and that's my favorite kind of
moment alright now we are going to talk
about North Korea yeah cuz you wrote a
book
you went there people don't even believe
you can go there so let's just start
with that how does one even go to North
Korea yeah it used to be legal until
very recently I saw my friend he had
gone he was on Facebook he met a kind
burning man who ran the tour company so
of course that's really all you need to
say well I knew a guy at Burning Man
so they were desperate because they
don't produce anything of value so
they're desperate for foreign currency
so this is one of their mechanisms for
doing it and there's one flight
in-and-out out of China or you could
take the train out of China which you
know as a New Yorker I take the train
enough already I was fine with that
right and you're there for a week and I
mean I hate all these people who go on a
trip and then it changed their life
forever and their Facebook goes whatever
but I mean when you see the thing that
drives me that gets to me is knowing
that every single person I met they're
still there like every kid I wave to and
every old lady on the street they're all
still prisoners at the regime yeah all
right so let's pause for a second so you
take a flight - you flew from New York
to China yeah and then and then a flight
to Pyongyang yeah it's in the last
terminal it's a one flight a day you
know although I talked away in the
Beijing Airport and even though it's
illegal to go now at that when you went
how many years ago is 2012 okay so not
that long ago
five years ago who was going there like
when you were on the plane like what
type of people were even go it was very
international my tour group there were a
bunch of Canadians there was a guy from
Belgium I believe a girl from Holland
yeah that a lot of Europeans liked it I
earlier I think this is the kind of
people who are like there's nothing else
like this on earth and let's see it you
know for what it is and as opposed to
what you're hearing in the press yeah
and when you get there what are the
security measures because obviously they
don't take too kindly to outsiders
especially people that you know or may
want to talk about what's quite the
opposite when you're there you're a
guest of the government so you are
treated extremely well it was safer
there than here because no one can do
anything to you because human life means
nothing and you were there as a resource
for this stage so you are treated very
well but when you land at least for me
your whole brain is screaming at you
like you don't belong here you know it's
it's this very kind of feeling it's
almost impossible to describe yeah so
tell me about your time there I mean I
could go I wrote an article at for
reasons calm for reason about it you
could look it up but it's you know my
whole principle there was to try to
break down my guide I do a lot of ghost
writing and when I do that I interview
the people kind of get inside their head
get past the press releases and I'm like
I'm gonna use those techniques of my god
to get her to kind of let me know what
she knows and there was this funny
moment how they're very quick I mean
this is what people don't get the North
Koreans have a sense of humor they're
having their humans in jail and they
have something there called Chu Li mo
which is a Pegasus which is the symbol
of speed and I asked my guide I go if I
could send you anything from the outside
world what do you want me to send you
she goes a Porsche and I go a lady I'm
not sending your Porsche I'm not sending
you Chile my either she goes we have the
original one here what do I need you to
send it sweetheart very very quick very
funny and she said she wanted perfume
and I go what kind of perfume and she
was struggling for the words and imagine
it's hard for us to describe perfume it
scent is not something that lends itself
to language and the word she was looking
for is feminine and this is someone who
was a millionaire soon and she can't buy
perfume because they don't have in the
whole country and I smuggled the perfume
in for her but it's it's when I was
telling her she had the same haircut my
mom had in
1981 my mom has jet-black straight hair
and I said you know talking to you makes
me realize a lot of what my mom went
through back in Russia and she just
stares at me she goes out then your
mother must have hated Russia and it was
this very chilling moment and someone
yeah this is a woman who obviously has a
pretty decent job and rich is she a
millionaire because of the job that to
eat will guide us so North Korea has
something called son bun which is a
hierarchy based on your loyalty to the
regime so the even step foot in
Pyongyang your family has to have a good
background right so to be talking to
foreigners you have to be off the charts
in terms of your family background and
one of the people you know stayed behind
on the tour and he did solo for a few
days and she told him all she wants to
do is travel the world and you know you
your job is to show tourists around and
you see college kids you know and you
get to see in like a my tour America
Canada Ireland
you know Belgium and you know you're
never gonna be able to go ever no matter
how much money you have no matter how
much power you have in fact anyone who's
a diplomat or something like that who
leaves North Korea for any reason their
family has to stay behind as hostages to
make sure you don't defect yeah I mean
that's what a crazy probably it's not
crazy it's brilliant I mean the level of
control this was I lay out my book this
was a methodical that this family got
this complete country under their total
control it was step by step closing the
doors putting up barriers hermetically
sealing them off from the outside world
yeah I guess I say crazy in that it's
like the crazy level authoritarian yes
you say brilliant as in not because you
like it
right of course because the the
mechanism that they use to create this
power yeah is pretty brilliant oh yeah
and it's it's so pervasive and it's so
much worse than people think like oh
they just have these crazy ideas about
the leaders it's much worse than that
it's it's so much worse than people
realize
yeah so I want to get to some of that
obviously but for your tour guide
because this is sort of fascinating to
me so this is a millionaire what does
that even mean
in North Korea you can't get perfume you
know what does that mean to be a
millionaire what that means and this is
to me the beginning of the end of the
North Korean regime it means you can
bribe their way out of trouble so if
when one of the first things I saw when
land the airport I was looking at the
parking lot in the back and when the
guards stopped like some rich lady and
by rich in North Korea she's dressed in
like a tea
closed right and she's on her cell and
he's basically like papers please and
she rolled her eyes at him didn't even
look at him showed her him whatever he
needed to and he waved her off and as
the regime has stopped being able to
provide for its citizenry the corruption
has spread throughout the country which
is a great step to bringing down a
country which is based on glorifying the
government right so now when you're
wealthy you can just pay whoever you
want to get whatever you want and that
is a you know a good step towards
getting people to in North Korea to
realize this is all a house of cards
yeah what a fascinating way to look at
things it's like now the corruption and
bribery is the good part yeah because
this means that the power is starting to
erode right they can't control it and
the best argument towards the
earnestness of their propaganda that the
Kim family are divine essentially is
this cynicism and just like here
realizing what we're being presented to
as the the overwhelming truth is
actually a barely poorly constructed lie
yeah so to that point give me some of
this so Kim Jong Il yes who was the
leader when you were there no he died
2011 okay so he had died what about two
two years before you were there
basically what do we need to know about
him versus the current leader Kim
jong-un
well when Kim jong-il took over and in
you so Kim jong-il was born in the World
War Two and died in 2011 so in my book
as he tells the story of his life he's
actually telling the whole history of
North Korea because like Forrest Gump
he's everywhere where something
important happens when he took over for
his father the founder of North Korea a
great leader Kim il-sung his campaign
slogan people think it's a joke it's not
was do not expect any change for me so
their whole principle is this mount
paektu bloodline which goes from father
to son to grandson now is a continuous
process that's going to bring forth the
revolution through the generations so
Kim jong-un people make fun of his hair
hair cut his haircuts that of his
grandfather from the 40s because he's
harkening back to that era and showing
this kind of sense of continuity through
the golden era of what North Korea was
actually competitive with the south so
what else do we know just
personality-wise because i think there's
such a cult of personality around him
you know people say well him and Trump
it's like the match made in hell because
they were there both erratic they're
both boisterous and they love head
and all of this I haven't seen anything
he's done that's erratic at all
I for example only by North Korean law
only someone who's a descendant of Kim
il-sung can be the leader right so Kim
jong-un is the youngest of three
brothers when he killed his eldest
brother Kim jong-nam who was passed over
that was an insurance policy there's no
Mike Pence there yeah can you just tell
that story a little bit because this was
just a couple years ago right no this is
a couple months ago in the airport didn
t kill but there was another brother
there well he had originally killed his
uncle and his uncle wasn't up for the
leadership position right but what
happened when Kim jong-il took over 94
and when Kim jong-un took over in 2011
what they did is have purges and killed
or you know made them instead exported
them or some of the countryside people
who were loyal loyal to their father
when people ask well why doesn't someone
just put a bullet in him the people at
the top are there not because of their
skills but because of their loyalty to
the man personally so the ID it's like
the idea of like you know John Podesta
telling Hillary Clinton you know you
should probably resign it will never
happen or any circumstances and
especially because if you do try that
you your family will have consequences
I'm even crazier than that because
basically all of their power resides in
that man correct system so that's that's
an interesting and important thing right
so and then the point
I always make when people are like oh
he's this crazy person if you look at
Qaddafi if you look at Saddam Hussein if
you look at Romania Ceausescu who is
very inspired by North Korea by his own
admission when these leaders go down
there usually shot or and with good
reasons so even if he wanted to kind of
step away from the gun I mean that guns
gonna be turned on him immediately yeah
what's it like for the average person
that's living there so now let's get
away from the million the millionaire
who is the millionaire is it all right
yes so right so he's a billionaire of
course yeah now we have a millionaire
tour guide who can't get perfume and yet
is and yet is expressing to you in
effect this kind of sucks but here we
are yeah what about for the average
person that you came across well I mean
they keep you away from the average
people so if there's a lot of extreme I
mean during the 90s when the famine hit
they chose to allow people to starve
rather than give them food from outside
world so if you go in like the
countryside I mean it's there's this
very famous picture of North Korea and I
compared to South Korea and it's just
this black void
Pyongyang so they don't have electricity
there trying to make subsistence
subsistence living as farmers and they
have to go to school and be taught their
propaganda so it's they're admitted now
there the propaganda has changed it used
to be that the whole world envies us and
now they're saying okay we're poor
country that's up and coming and that's
preserving Korean as' so it's I mean
it's just you know being a poor farmer
is is what it's like yeah although they
kept you away from the average person
how much of outside world ideas can
actually seep through so I suspect
someone like the tour guide it's pretty
obvious you were able to get some ideas
across she had some sense oh yes of the
outside she and her Gangnam style she
didn't get half the lyrics but that's
the level because when you're in
Pyongyang it's like being in New York or
you think of yourself as this
international cosmopolitan so everyone
in Pyongyang has these big heels they
like to pride themselves and being
cultured and civilized so but
increasingly thanks to cell phones
thanks to people being refugees and and
memory sticks people are getting an
understanding of the outside world in
North Korea which is also very healthy
they used to be taught that South Korea
you know they they have to wear gas
masks and the pollution and that the
women are raped by American soldiers in
order to give them aids and things like
this and now you just look across the
Tumen River into China in these towns
and you're like they have electricity at
night
why don't we and it's as simple as that
yeah so I sense that your prescription
for all this would be that it will
crumble under its own weight not only
because of everything that you've just
described but also technology will
eventually it can't they can't stop it
with borders that yeah they can shut the
internet but there's just a zillion
other ways now there's this great quote
from either Steinbeck or Faulkner I
always forget and it says how did you go
bankrupt and the answer was two ways
gradually and then suddenly so this is
exactly how the Soviet Union came down
because in this during the 80s you had
all these women in Russia watching
Dallas and dynasty and saying why on
this show does the maid have a fur coat
and I'm wiping my ass with literal
newspaper and it's as simple as that you
can tell people Kim jong-un is the
greatest thing since sliced bread or a
sliced chemistry whatever you want to
call it at the end the day you want your
kid to have food and if this other
alternative is I'm gonna have food for
my children it's as simple as that
yeah so just some of this explain what's
going on with
these missile tests lately that this is
you know creating some sort of crisis
which allows him to double down on it's
not a crisis this is well an appearance
of a crisis now from there but look so
Kim jong-il the leading philosophy of
North Korea is the juichi idea which is
invented by Kim Il Sung Kim jong-il
changed that to the Sun gun idea which
means military first and what he meant
is the military is the basis of our
country which preserves all the other
freedoms that we have and he said in
order to fight the American Eagle and
the Chinese dragon and the Russian bear
I have to turn North Korea into a
hedgehog and what he meant by this is an
animal with missiles at every direction
and it said Kim jong-nam the eldest son
wanted to demilitarize and Kim jong-un
ill just said no no it's these missiles
that are going to keep us safe so look
at it from his perspective he's a
country the size of Pennsylvania
he has gotten the entire UN against him
he's making a fool of America on a daily
basis and laughing about it in the
photos and he's saying look we're tiny
and look how strong I've made us and
these US imperialists as they call us
who tried to kill us during the Korean
War and are biding their time to come
back and kill us all
I'm the one keeping us safe so it's not
even a crisis so much as it's more of a
credit our reaction is much more of a
crisis because we're all hysterical and
he's like hahaha what are you gonna do
about it right that's interesting so our
reaction is a crisis because you're
because basically you're saying
everything that he's doing is very
logical with yeah within the system that
he's doing things yes it all makes sense
so that's not a crisis how we deal with
it without understanding a lot of the
things you're talking about is the
actual crisis so when these tests go off
you think this is just more showboating
sort of to double down on that right
it's both it's also commercial so North
Korea has always complained about how is
it the United States is the biggest arms
deal in the world and we don't have the
right to sell our arms so by doing this
they can show every little dictator look
how good our weaponry is and it's going
to be available for sale and look what
it can do to America and it'll you know
it'll be the best kind of home security
system you're ever gonna have yeah it's
kind of funny because obviously you're
talking about so many things that are
really wrong in terms of human right
here a freedom is and the things that
you really care about and yet also I can
sense there's a certain level of
admiration or something
for that maybe that respect yeah I guess
respect for is just somebody that
created a system that has some value in
a bizarre way they are very bright
people and they're very evil people so I
always talk about this compared to like
your comic book the Batman bill and the
Joker because people see the clown but
that clown has a lot of bodies behind
them and that clown has pulled off a lot
of stunts in his day so the idea that
he's the silly idiot it's like this
silly idiot they've been around for 70
years if they're suicidal they're doing
a really bad job of it and they've
outlasted everyone except for Cuba yeah
you know it's interesting that's one of
the things that I have come around on
Trump the idea of Trump at least when
all these people all day long he's such
an idiot he's making these decisions
every two seconds he doesn't know what's
going on it's like if that's actually
true and he became president like that
then we're all just the worst
soccer's ever you don't even like then
what does that say about the rest of us
and actually you know it means so you
have to I think if someone has risen to
that level of power it doesn't mean you
like them it doesn't mean you respect
them as people or anything else but you
have to acknowledge like there's a
little something going on and I talked
about this very heavily my book because
when you go there they brag about their
strategy so you know Kim jong-il is very
boastful of his techniques and they've
been very effective because when he took
over in 1994 they mentioned Krauthammer
by name and their literature like they
all think it's not gonna last no six
months and now it's 2017 and they're
still there so despite all the
predictions despite all the claims that
these people are stupid and crazy and
incompetent Kim jong-un's hold on power
is pretty strong and this is not an
accident this is at the cost of humanity
and it cost a human life and the cost of
anything that you and I hold decent and
moral so I know that everybody always
wants America to do everything it's like
they always want America to do
everything and then every time we do
anything then they hate us for it so
we're sort of in our own karmic insanity
yeah that to that regard but what about
the other countries they're China most
particularly right what do they make of
what's happening there they're seeing
tests go off I mean I know that one of
these Rockets just went over Japan sure
from what I understand like what are all
those countries thinking about what's
really happening China doesn't want an
American ally in their border China
doesn't want 25 million North Korea
who have never who don't speak Chinese
or who haven't been in a computer
swarming the boardroom setting up camp
in Manchuria so they're in a tough spot
but China has turned their back on North
Korea a couple of times when in North
Korea they built this gigantic gold
statue of Kim il-sung
in the town square the Chinese said look
we're communists this network we're
about so they changed it to bronze all
right and right that's correct yeah and
you have to go that if you go to my
website you could see a photo of me next
the statues I called it leadership if in
the 80s North Korea for a very long time
thought having north and south both in
the UN because that would make permanent
the idea these are two countries divided
the North regards Korea as one country
and China in the 80s turned their back
on that and both countries are allowed
in so these were two moments that China
has turned their back on North Korea but
the same time if you North Korea just
recently Kim jong-un pointed out the
this latest thought was a hydrogen bomb
was made using homegrown ingredients
that's the way of saying you could
sanction us you can make exports illegal
we can still build them and there's
nothing you could do about it he just
had a storage of like was a 1 million
gallons or something of oil pointing out
even if you seal us up from the outside
world these tests are going to continue
even if China turns their back on us
yeah so was this hydrogen bomb test the
true game changer in your mind because
of that I think the game has been played
the same way for decades which is we are
going to do whatever it takes to
maintain our hold on power and we're
gonna revel in the fact that we're going
to in their words slap America across
the face yeah and then at the same time
in a weird way they can do whatever they
want because as you just said China
doesn't want them collapsing and right
having to deal with either a migrant
crisis or an immigrant crisis or what of
any other military crisis that's gonna
end and they're all taught as soon as
things go bad you've got a hit Seoul as
hard and fast as possible now the
imagery forget if you think that anouk's
the imagery of a city like Seoul a city
of skyscrapers getting hit by missiles
is apocalyptic yeah if you were a South
Korean what would you think of this
whole situation they don't really they
they're fine with that they've been
living with this for a very long time
and this is not freaking them out so I
don't I I was at I ran into some South
Korean tourists and they didn't really
even know who Kim jong-il was so this is
how little they care about the north and
it's actually very sad when a lot of
North Korean refugees make their way the
south they're treated very very poorly
do their accents and so on and in fact
they're short
if I I don't know what I would make of
the situation probably is I'd feel even
more kinship you know I feel a lot of
kinship to the North Korean people
because again it's some parallel it's
what my family went through I think I
feel that even more if I was living in
the South especially if I was meeting
these refugees and interacting with them
it's just heartbreaking all right so
just sort of wrap up the the military
side of this thing so when we hear all
this back and forth these days and we
hear about the hydrogen bomb and
everything else I sense basically you
think that this is probably just
posturing on both sides and nothing
really is gonna I think we're playing
chicken and both cars are going at each
other at the speed that they can and
it's going to be a question of who
blinks first and what it's going to take
to blink but so that's a lot scarier
than my question yeah it's not just pop
I mean he is built militarizing and
building up these weaponry that's not
just posturing yeah all right so then as
someone that I think basically do you
vote for trumpet I don't believe in
voting no okay so but as someone that I
think basically likes Trump you'd
explain why you I also liked Hillary
because she destroyed healthcare for a
generation I mean if you look at Nixon
how much he brought he brought leftist
ideas into power an incompetent foe is
very very useful you couldn't have had
Obama without Bush right so everything
she's touched she's such a walking
calamity she almost lost the primary to
someone who wasn't even in her party so
she would have done great things for the
right if she had been president and you
certainly couldn't have had Trump
without Clinton so it's kind of yes it
does kind of make sense that being said
as someone that basically likes what's
happened to the system be correct Ron do
you think Trump has the capacity either
mental or otherwise to deal with this
game of chicken is there someone else
that you would have preferred I don't
think anyone has a good answer to this
issue including me but I'm very
heartened by hearing the Rex Tillerson
and Madison all other people saying and
Bannon recently said it you know he goes
we all know that military conflict with
North Korea would be absolutely
catastrophic you see some conservatives
saying Kim jong-un insulted us so
therefore we should bomb his country to
oblivion you're gonna take the moral
high ground and kill 25 million slaves
because someone assaulted you no go to
hell so there's a very strong
understanding in the White House that
military conflict would be the worst
possible course yeah which I would never
want but I always think it's interesting
how anytime someone says something about
them
I mean the average person I think
doesn't understand what deterrence is
anymore or just doesn't understand what
some posturing is or what public stay
right are so they make it seem like
anyone who ever says anything about the
military or we might do this or we're
all options are on the table whatever
but they're automatically the war
mongers right and in effect it's almost
completely reverse actually we saw this
just right recently so North Korea said
we're bombing Guam in August yeah and
Trump went on TV and said they're gonna
face fire in fury like the world has
never seen in Chuck Schumer who doesn't
know anything about this issue and I
don't blame em was like this is this you
know reckless rhetoric isn't helping
well I'm still here yeah so obviously
when you're speaking of someone on their
level they're going to have an ability
to communicate with you and it worked
how do we explain that concept to people
because it's one of the things that
drives me crazy more than anything else
when you see this because if we were
just saying all the time we're never
gonna do anything you can do whatever
you wanna buy buy buy even though I'm
not an interventionist by nature and all
those things but it just doesn't really
like encompass anything that's even how
humans react to each other I think most
people that say 90% are complete and
capable of empathy by which I mean
understanding things from other
perspectives you know this is the whole
book was about North Korea's perspective
I think they think this is how I act in
my normal life therefore this is how you
should act on a world scale it's as
simple as that yeah and we got to get
that those two things to match up a
little bit more we got to stop and
relying on the masses to make our
choices which is also a sort of scary
proposition in a way don't you think no
it's the opposite of scary what do you
mean well that you want some input from
your populace and now as to some so
you'd prefer so at the end of this
anarchist view you'd prefer that just
some elite it's not some of its it's
like this my rights are not up for
discussion let alone a vote so as soon
as we all sit down to discuss that I've
already lost I you are entitled to your
religion you're entitled to your life
your time to raise your kids as much as
you want
I don't know you I don't want to know
you and I don't care what you think
about anything and I'm not interested
persuading you I'm interested in
stopping you from implementing your
ideas on my life in my personal right
but what is that in real-world sense
what does that mean for if we were to
just apply all of that to America in
2017 what does that mean it means
freedom no no I get it I get it on the
intellectual side truly I understand but
in terms of how we would change the
government
the overheads happening now making
political discourse impossible making it
impossible for any bills to pass ever
but then what's that oh because you'd
argue then that basically the government
becomes sort of just irrelevant
altogether yeah yeah and you'd want to
live in this sort of endless stalemate
because basically it would allow us all
to just turn back and rely on once there
is and once you see government is not a
mechanism for affecting socials change
the system starts to break down and
you're gonna see healthier consequence
this is my opinion yeah can you give me
an example of where that oh I guess so
what you're saying is that's what
happens sort of in Russia oh yeah from
when it was the time when you were there
and when your parents were there - now
even though there's obviously a lot of
immersion there's this blog called slate
starving Union this blog called slate
start codex and he pointed out that our
best mechanism nowadays of self
segregation is not by race it's not by
culture it's by ideology and the more
that happens which is a function of
social media where you can only talk to
people that you agree with if politics
are important to you I think the better
that is because this freedom Association
is essential American freedom and it's
one that the left and many times the
right does not regard as essential and
the more that happens I think the happy
everyone's gonna be it's so interesting
because it's sort of countered of the
way I try to do this show and I like
hearing about ideas from everyone on
both sides and I'm trying to build some
bridges and even in my own life I build
bridges with people that I've had on the
show but I do understand the premise of
what you're saying here so and but I but
I obviously might the bulk of of my
existence leans to the other side on
this in terms of you know finding some
of that agreement I have no problem with
finding agreement I have the problem
with those with ideas being imposed on
me and I think that is all politics is
is oppression so your this is what
anarchy is this is what anarchy is
you're looking at it right face of
Anarchy you mentioned the the that some
of the people get out of North Korea
just to quickly go back to them yeah cuz
I don't wanna lose that who actually
gets out how do they actually do it well
one of the great things and this just
shows the evil and the brilliance of the
regime when they were unable to feed the
border guards if you bribe the border
guard
let you go now what the regime has smart
enough to do is they allow the border
guard to keep the bribe as long as they
turn you in so but this was a very big
mechanism people crossing the Tumen
River is very shallow between North
Korea and China
so people needs border towns like go
into China all the time there were
smugglers whose job it is to kind of get
people cuz you are officially a South
Korean citizen if you're North Korean so
as long as you step foot in a South
Korean embassy you're home free wait can
you repeat that as well if you are
officially a South Korean citizen if
you're a North Korean right they're both
recognized Korea's one country so if you
step foot in a South Korean embassy or
in the South Korean airport you're safe
mmm interesting tell me about the
demilitarized zone because I think
people have this idea of just like this
like bizarre corridor of nothingness
right what's actually going on well
there's a very funny story in the Gerald
Ford administration because people are
like North Korea has never done anything
like this there was a tree in the
Demilitarized Zone which is between the
two Koreas and the Americans took an axe
and they wanted to prune it and the
North Koreans took that axe and chopped
up the American soldiers that axe is now
on display in North Korea I've seen with
my own eyes bloody and the Americans
came back with operation Paul Bunyan and
they had a huge force and they pruned
that tree and they left the stump just
as a finger to the North Koreans so
there's been a lot of call these
conservatives on the air who are like
they've never seen anything like this
you have they've captured USS Pueblo in
the 1968 it's still there they killed
one the crewmen but when you're at the
DMZ I mean it you got the North Korean
guard staring at each other you have the
South Korean guards it's kind of it's
funny coming in from the North Korean
side you know and seeing it but it's the
most militarized border on earth there's
like full of landmines but the North
Koreans would plow right through it if
they want to invade Seoul in seconds how
big is it actually one what is it
there's a strip it's like there's like a
strip there's like I think five
buildings two of which are north to her
south and one neutral yeah it was kind
of closed down for repairs when I was
there and the north there's this big
hulking brutalist building that you get
to look out of the balcony and look into
the South from and everyone has all
these cameras pointed at each other yeah
I feel I should ask you for a few
predictions on some of this stuff on
North Korea yeah I think we're seem to
be in the end
and I think Kim jungle and even just
given his age it's nowhere near as smart
as his dad I think he's freaking out I
think otto warmbier was a very big
mistake on their part and I think I
think Trump cares enough about human
rights and is reckless enough is in a
sense to be like alright I'm going to
see the end of this regime before the
end of my presidency at least that's
what he says yeah all right now a little
prediction on America because we've got
some of this stuff happening - yeah I
think things are internal chaos
happening I think there's gonna be more
chaos I think it's the healthiest thing
possible I think the right has now
understood the rules and is exploiting
them to their advantage for example I
talked with this Kathy Griffin thing hit
I talked to a lot of my buddies on the
right and I'm like how are you offended
by this when you put up all these awful
memes and they go we're not this is a
scalp and they got her a week later they
got reza aslan fired from CNN so rather
than having this old conservative model
of buckley who's the great villain
standing a thorn hillary history yelling
stop it's like we actually want to stop
we actually are going to do something
about it and force people to kind of
have casualties on their side and I
think vannin strategy which she kind of
let slip is the more we make this a
cultural fight the more they're going to
lose because the more they're going to
get into hysteria
now here's an example that for decades
you know as I said earlier calling
someone a racist is an effective
mechanism because most people are scared
that they're racist in the sense of if
you meet some from other country you
don't want to offend them accidentally
you don't it's a problem no one is
scared to their closet Nazi no one is
scared their closet white supremacists
so if you're telling the laymen you know
you're a Nazi it's like my dad fought my
grandfather fought like what are you
talking about that there even though the
rhetoric has escalated the effectiveness
has decreased and in my view this is a
sign of them freaking out that they've
lost control of the megaphone yeah and I
have hit this point a couple of times on
the show that the desperation and yes
why we're seeing the violence because
they've lost the ideas you know again to
reference the the Ben Shapiro at
Berkeley thing there were signs up about
we don't want white supremacists right
Hampus ben shapiro an Orthodox Jew right
it gets more on I think they've measured
it he's gotten more online eight from
the alt-right or whatever that thing is
then
anybody and it's like he got he goes to
show up there to give you some basic
conservative views and we're saying we
don't want white supremacists here like
that it's just basically the chart has
been completely obliterated oh yeah yeah
and and the the because they're not able
to enforce their edicts any longer now
they have to do in a ground level so
rather than taking out entire classes of
people like back in the day now that I
have to go people one-on-one so for the
violence part I I mean I suspect you
don't want just violence to be erupting
all over the place but you see do you
almost see that as a necessary piece of
this now I think it's for an inevitable
peace I guess is a better the three
villains are the media the government
and the universities right so the the
media and the government have been
discredited the university is still very
much a boudreaux aspiration for
Americans like my kids the first one to
go to college you know this is such a
big deal you need a degree to make
something of yourself I've never taken a
writing course I didn't want to waste
time educating professors now I don't
care where you are in the political
spectrum quick thank you I don't know
where you are in the political spectrum
I don't care if you're a human or an
animal if you see fire you're against it
we saw this in Ferguson and it gave the
Republicans the biggest landslide ever
and we're seeing it now if you look at a
university and you're seeing the schools
being burned down if you're seeing your
daughter go to school is a pretty young
17 year old and coming out looking like
a smart walrus as a parent you are going
to be against this and this is a very
important next step towards breaking the
last piece of progress ISM because the
goal of the university is to turn young
children into the shock troops or the
progressive militia
man I think we can do a couple hours
you're gonna have to look how often you
get out to LA as a Brooklyn guy when my
next book and then you're right hits we
can we can talk about this when's that
one drop April April and then and in
between then we'll we'll see on Fox
Business and Selena
where else will they accept these crazy
ideas compound Mediacom my show once the
show compound media that's through
that's through Gavin this Anthony comia
Gavin just left yeah Gavin just a little
writer so a few people left I guess just
gather it was it just Gavin yeah and so
humans doing that and he's been he's
been through the the Machine himself
yeah yeah crazy degree they I mean they
cost him his job that's a whole other
yeah yeah yeah we will hit on next time
and we'll get you back in here and
to discuss the book and for more on
Michael I suspect he has plenty more to
say follow him on the Twitter machine at
Michael malice
[Music]
you